por acá en la región chilena de
valparaíso los camiones aljibes forman
parte habitual de un cada vez más
desértico paisaje circular los siete
días de la semana a casi cualquier hora
y son vitales para casi la mitad de la
comuna más de 30.000 personas
recientemente el tribunal supremo
reconoció el agua como un derecho
fundamental y ordenó al estado chileno a
que proporcionen 100 litros diarios a
sus habitantes pero 100 litros no dan
para mucho terrible porque imagina este
ir al baño
[Música]
y cada vez que usted tira la cadena son
5 litros de agua que se van entonces
para nosotros acá cerca pues terrible
vivir con 100 litros de agua
juanita es experta en el gasto de agua
que implica cada acción cotidiana y en
su reciclaje
en su grifo solo corre el agua 45
minutos al día un lujo de indiano que no
se repite todo el año
como uno de los encargados de entregar
el agua tito es muy querida en la comuna
de petorca su labor le da mucha
felicidad pero también para triste
la verdad toda la gente igual toda la
gente igual espera su agüita de repente
donde hay familia no ha tocado con ser
una familia donde son seis personas seis
niños y un macho bueno que llegó hace
poco y da pena
mientras citó se ve obligado a dejar
agua racionada familias en pandemia no
lejos de allí la agroindustria usa
derechos privados de agua consagrados en
la constitución del dictador augusto
pinochet para un cultivo que requiere
cantidades ingentes aguacates de
exportación muchos para europa el litro
por segundo de agua cuesta en esta zona
hasta 19 mil dólares
con chile el agua es objeto de lucro
dulzura y de exclusión y está puesta al
árbitro una industria atractiva y ahí
donde se prioriza el agua pero no la
vida salvaguardar la vida las
comunidades hoy día el negocio del agua
un negocio especulativo es un negocio
que no tiene ninguna regulación que se
rige por los códigos de la oferta y la
demanda un caso único en el mundo que se
quiere cambiar en la nueva constitución
mientras el negocio de los aguacates
crece un 30 por ciento anual y los
empresarios ya buscan nuevos lugares
donde poder ejercer sus derechos de agua
cuando los cauces de esta zona se agoten
completamente